[Générique d'intro]
[musique sacrée]
[hors champ] : Ok, coupez, elle est bonne !
[sonnerie stridente]
[voix féminine] : C'est coupé, merci !
Ok. Nickel. La Lune, c'est bon, tu peux la replier,
On n'en a plus besoin.
Euh... Est-ce qu'on peut m'éteindre le Soleil, là ?
Il fait un peu chaud.
- Avant d'éteindre le Soleil, on peut faire un son seul ?
Oui, si tu veux, oui, euh... Ok.
Merci tout le monde, c'était le dernier plan
de tous les habitants de la Terre. Merci !
*applaudissements* *petits cris*
[hors champ] : C'était un projet ambitieux, oui,
on avait plus de 3 milliards d'années de "rushs"
[NDT : rush=séquence vidéo]
et on a dû en faire un film de 200 000 ans, au final.
Donc le montage était un processus assez long, oui.
- Et l'élaboration d'un tel projet, ça prend beaucoup de temps ?
- En fait, le plus long, c'était la construction des décors,
ça nous a pris à peu près un milliard d'années
avant de trouver un truc un peu... un peu potable.
Et après on a dû attendre.
[...]
C'est bon ?
C'est bon, y'a de la vie !
*cris de joie exultante, applaudissements*
[hors champ] : Moi j'aimais bien les dinosaures, hein
mais la production me mettait pas mal la pression
parce que ça coûtait trop cher, c'était pas assez intéressant,
du coup j'ai dû... J'ai dû les virer.
Mais après, il y a eu les humains.
Et là... Là, c'était intéressant, oui.
- Alors, justement, comment on peut raconter une histoire
avec autant de personnages ? C'est incroyable !
- Alors, c'est sûr, c'est pas évident
de raconter 107 milliards d'histoires,
mais chaque vie était différente.
Chaque vie avait sa singularité et était très intéressante, vraiment.
Sauf celle d'Edouard Boulin, lui, je l'ai enlevé du film.
- Comment étaient vos rapports avec vos comédiens ?
- Eh bien au départ, j'avais un scénario d'écrit,
mais je suis le genre de réalisateur, déjà,
qui réécrit pas mal sur le tournage,
et au bout d'un moment, je me suis rendu aperçu
que j'avais plus besoin d'écrire,
parce que les humains proposaient
des choses vraiment, vraiment incroyables.
- Alors je suis intervenu quelques fois au début, par-ci, par-là,
pour leur donner mes indications de jeu,
ce que je voulais qu'ils fassent, ce qu'ils fassent pas,
mais j'ai très vite arrêté parce que...
Eh ben déjà, ils faisaient des guerres en mon nom,
ça, c'était vraiment chaud,
et pour les laisser se débrouiler entre eux, parce que...
Ca reste leur histoire, c'est pas la mienne.
*GROS soupir*
*cris de panique lointains*
- Justement, votre "meilleur" souvenir de tournage ?
- J'ai pas de "souvenir" en particulier.
Les humains sont des êtres très intéressants,
je les ai connus à l'état de petit organisme
et je les ai vu grandir jusqu'à arriver à une espèce
qui cherche à comprendre d'où elle vient,
et qui cherche à expliquer et à savoir.
Ils n'arrêtaient pas de me surprendre,
et ils proposaient des choses vraiment vraiment incroyables !
Sauf... Edouard Boulin.
Toutes ces vies si différentes avaient au final les mêmes thèmes :
la recherche du bonheur, l'amour, la mort...
Très intéressant leur rapport à la mort.
Et c'est un pur bonheur, pour un réalisateur,
de voir une histoire se construire d'elle-même, petit à petit,
et de les voir tous lutter pour s'occuper des gens qu'ils aiment.
- Votre pire souvenir de tournage, c'est lequel ?
- Plus belle la vie... Hein, ça c'était horrible.
- Alors, maintenant, la question que tout le monde se pose :
est-ce qu'il y aura une suite ?
- Ecoutez, on se concentre sur la promo du film en ce moment,
mais euh... Mais en tous cas l'envie est là, oui,
Etant donné que les humains sont allés coloniser une autre planète...
On peut raconter leur histoire et ça peut être vachement intéressant.
Et puis maintenant, les humains, ils ont des sabres lasers, et tout,
donc on peut faire des trucs ultra-stylés.
- Merci beaucoup et bravo parce que... Je crois que c'était pas évident.
[jingle] : SURICATE !
*bruits de pas*
[musique mélancolique]
[voix féminine, hors champ] : Tu viens ?
- Mmh ?
[musique mélancolique]
[bredouillant ] : Eh ben, commencez à y aller, je... Je vous rejoins.
*lumières qui s'éteignent*
[musique mélancolique]
*bruit de chute fracassante*
[...]
[musique mélancolique]